مناسبه التحويلات الماليه للعاملين في
الخارج اهميه متزايده في العقود الاخيره
خاصه للدول الناميه كونها مصدرا مهما
للنقد الاجنبي بعد الصادرات ويظهر تاثير
ذلك جليا على النمو الاقتصادي من خلال
تعزيز راس المال البشري بزياده معدلات
الانتاج والاستهلاك دعم الانفاق على
القطاعات الاقتصاديه وزياده الادخار
والاستثمار تقلل هذه التحويلات من مستويات
الفقر لكنها في المقابل تتاثر بعدد من
العوامل منها الظروف الاقتصاديه في مناطق
الارسال والاستقبال معدلات البطاله معدلات
الفائده الحقيقيه سعره صرف العملات
والاستقرار الامني والسياسي واخيرا
التشريعات المنظمه لها ارسالا واستقبالا
وكشف البنك الدولي ان تلك التحويلات
ارتفعت في الدول منخفضه ومتوسطه الدخل
بنحو 5% لتصل الى 626 مليار دولار تقريبا
في العام الماضي بينما يقدروان يصل حجم
تحويلات عالميا الى نحو 800 مليار دولار
ومن المتوقع ان تكون الهند على راس اكبر
خمس دول متلقيه لتحويلات في العام الماضي
برقم قياسي جديد قدرهم 100 مليار دولار
تله المكسيك بواقع 60 مليار دولار لكن ما
هو حجم تحويلات العاملين في الخارج في
الدول العربيه الفقيره ومتوسطه الدخل في
مصر بلغت قيمه هذه التحويلات في العام
الماضي اكثر من 32 مليارا وثلث مليار
دولار في العام الماضي وهو ما يمثل السته
19% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
في المغرب بلغت القيمه 11 مليارا و 400
مليون دولار وفي لبنان 6 مليارات و800
مليون دولار في الاردن سجلت اربعه مليارات
و 700 مليون دولار في تونس مليارين و 100
مليون دولار وفي الجزائر بلغت القيمه
مليارا و800 مليون دولار وفي السودان بلغت
القيمه مليار دولار اي ما يعادل
424% من الناتج المحلي
ويتوقع البنك الدولي ان تتباطا وتيره هذه
التحويلات في العام الجاري جراء المخاوي
في من حدوث ردود الاقتصادي العالمي
وتداعيات قفزه معدلات التضخم العالميه
واستمرار حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وتقل
باسعار الطاقه واسعار صرف العملات